saying if i send a
donation can it be added to a youtube
video
i'd like to have my girlfriend hear it
when i watch the video on youtube
that's a funny request um
but i i guess i consider it it has to be
like family friendly come to england you
should visit stafford
also do you want to play a stafford
against me i sent you a challenge on
liches ooh my username is turnos
i have 257
pending challenges
wait i played followers several times
before
i'll play e4 again
i may have played e4 last time hard to
remember
let's see what followers is up to
play ponziani
oh let's play i feel inspired from the
last game
i'm gonna try and get a belgrade gambit
which happens after knight f6 d4
takes and then then knight d5
okay so it looks like we're gonna go
into a belgrade
i haven't played this in ages
this main starting position so rather
than recapturing the pawn
this would be a four night scotch i go
for a slightly more confusing position
okay bishop c5 i know is a playable move
probably one of the more natural moves
i think i can play bishop g5 here
this is one of the points whoa it's teoh
hi maria the first don't think i would
have survived the past you're in
lockdown without you let alone
enjoy it this much i love you bunna oh
that's so sweet
oh shout out to maria i'm so kind
now i guess i'll have to put this video
on youtube now
this better turn into a fun game
well thank you thank you teochaki a very
kind donation
and thanks to maria for keeping
teochwaki company
that was really sweet got some hearts in
the chat
can i i take
look at this
oh chad is so so loving right now
good morning hearts for maria
good morning to dq'd
okay so i think already it's an opening
success
um even though i'm still down the pawn
kingside structure is damaged youtube
video
oh i appreciate that yeah uh thanks m
what is his name ambequif um
yeah twitch twitch chat being a nice
role model for
for the youtube people
okay so i won back the pawn
yeah i'm not sure what black should have
done there maybe like bishop
bishop e6 keeping the pawn defended but
yeah now life is very good
i want to play f4
a few different approaches in this
position depending what block does
c6 is respectable i have to to move the
knight away
playing that f4
i still want to target f6 and the way to
do that
could be something like knight h5 and
then
some eventual queen intrusion
that's some point night five as well
whoa thank you for the hours of
education thank you
animated love from ireland i appreciate
all the love and support
and thank you for flying hi eric are you
friends with any of the other chess
streamers you play on here in real life
oh definitely oh in real life
yeah definitely i'm friends with
i feel like most streamers i've at least
met before
in real life
wait let me focus here
i have this move
yeah let's play b4 forcing the
bishop to basically trade and then i'll
get a nice pawn center
now he has to retreat
i mean first of all i'm i'm technically
roommates with chess bras
uh we're friendly share a place in st
louis even though even though they're
more based in canada
uh yeah friends with with rey
i mean rey robson irene
um basically anyone who attended webster
university
uh chesweeb
um a lot of
a lot of grand masters who study in st
louis
yeah played ping pong with nerditsuki
in georgia a couple years ago
levy of course yeah i stayed at levi's
place in new york
just over a year ago
fabi fabi doesn't really stream but we
did
i think when i first moved to saint
louis we were both on the chest bra
stream
there's some video on youtube
he was playing blindfold chess i was
making the moves
we were playing from the setup too okay
let's take the
pawn
trying to show no mercy this game
so i'm up upon not bad for
being down the pawn off the opening
i still probably have to develop like
bring the bishop in
go for a5
or just win on time
yeah let's play a4
oh free rook or
did my opponent just just do an oh no my
rook
wanting me to take after it takes i get
forked um
i could take your fur i could also play
this first
there's really no rush i'll do this
first chasing the
queen back to c7
because everything's covered here
and now i can take the rook
yeah life is very good here
there's an idea i want to play bishop a6
but
not quite working maybe queen here
oh there's a cool idea
involves oh no my knight and oh no my
rook please play this
i'm gonna give more time don't resign
don't flag
i'll show it after the game there's a
really cool idea
it's not gonna happen now
okay let's go for the ultimate squeeze
oh okay with check yeah it's a nice kind
of squeeze formation
i don't mind giving away the rook to get
a pawn on c6
hey connect five
oh maybe i'll try and win connect six
and then it'll be extra youtube worthy
oh but if i play this i
potentially lose a pawn
wait a minute how do i do this
i have to play this first
okay well i'll i'll win connect six with
my queen
okay that was a fun kind of belgrade
gamut
i can imagine this could be some form of
thumbnail
uh thank you followers for the game so
there is a really cool line i wanted to
i was hoping
to get um
it didn't quite pan out but if we go
back
to
[Music]
this position
oh maybe it wouldn't have worked
never mind i was thinking d5
i was gonna play queen g3 say oh no my
knight and then i was gonna say oh no my
rook
but this isn't mate because king d7
so hopefully i would have realized that
before it was too late
um
because like this sort of setup there
there's all these mating ideas
i guess with the queen here i i would
need to keep my knight on f6
so if h4 oh this still isn't
mate but it would be um it'd still be a
nice combination
because there's queen b7 then takes
anyway um maybe i can provide
one one lesson of more like practical
value
when you're black in this position hi
youtube chat big love from toggy and
rose and thank you m rose and here
youtube
oh hi hi yeah youtube say hi to tagi
and maria and everyone else who's saying
hi
but one last lesson how to play against
the belgrade
so when white plays this
as far as i know the best move here
it's it's a little bit weird looking
because it violates a couple opening
principles
but the move to play is knight b4
moving the same piece twice away from
the center
the point is we're challenging the knot
on d5
and then whichever knight black tape or
whichever night white takes uh it'll be
completely fine for black if it takes
takes we uh we check
and we're up a pawn this is really good
if
takes this way there's takes and white
can't actually recapture the pawn
if queen d4 we fork triple fork
and if knight takes d4 black to move
black to move and get a winning position
um final puzzle
good job to jion
mill and hector bat and everyone else
who sang
queen takes d4 that's a nice tactical
pattern
oh no my queen but oh no
all your pieces got and
black will be up at night
um so yeah after night before
the computer computer approves i guess
this is a main line
and then oh yeah if e5 i believe there's
queen
yeah queen g6 hitting c2 is nice
anyway so this is why the belgrade isn't
popular
but uh i think it's still
like you can still get away with
belgrade against most players because
most people don't know about this move
and then when this happens yeah this is
really fun
so that will go on youtube um
thanks youtube people for watching
say hi to tagi say hi to maria and
teotwaki
and everyone else in twitch chat